welcome back to the gentleman oh oh
Steve yes Mary I did retail I'm excited
super excited this is not about me
making fun of you or you her i'm staying
to me make fun of gal yes this all about
love today Steve oh yeah like
valentine's day here in the dojo studios
we are very excited there are two we've
never done a two-part episode before
sure this is a very special after school
edition two parts the one where where is
it Gordon jump goes after Dudley at the
bike store the Maytag man who would tell
a child molester yeah remember that
awful member he was like typecast after
doing that he's tried to get Dudley into
the yeah yeah yeahs never heard from him
again but never did so ah although if
they did make a made-for-tv movie Roy
Wood jr. could be the grown-up does what
it could be we're excited listen very
excited we're very excited we're doing a
part two of somebody this is very
excited yeah very think of all the
guests we've had what 76 77 f that
landing yeah baby this could be the most
anticipated way for me well like oh this
is going to be amazing I thought you
were pumped about this exciting well it
does definitely lead back we had on
Chris Porter and you and the gang went
down to san juan capistrano saw corey
feldman VI Feldman yes and his angels
yes angelic to the core yep we saw the
concert ah blown away I think all of us
were anticipating as comedians would be
yet little pessimistic let's go in
sheriff have some laughs and we'll leave
and then we all left thinking wow that
was pretty awesome yeah you like I great
show just like a great presence like you
wanted to root for the guy the whole
time yeah and aam I like I think we
mentioned in part one I think half the
people were there too because they are
genuine fans that are music right and
then there's another half that's curious
you want to see the spectacle you want
to see what is all the hubbub about and
we
they went in thinking you know assuming
the worst yeah we completely got just
sucker-punched yeah yeah this dude's
pretty sweet so loved the show well you
posted this huge huge article on your
facebook page yeah about how you went in
thinking what it was going to be yeah
thought it's gonna be one way completely
turned to the other way did all the guys
you one would feel the same way or
everybody really everybody before the
show we were all laughing like yeah
there's gonna be great this can be so
funny we got to take pictures I said and
then you know within the first song or
two what kind of look at each other like
it's pretty good and then the middle the
show is like so actually pretty fun
right and then the ANA so it's like we
got to do this again sure it was that
kind of vibe the whole show and look
this is you know yeah I mean you've been
around comics you what you don't call
yourself one but sorry hangers-on yeah
yeah but I mean look it was it was
absolutely a great time I would strongly
suggest to anybody instead of going to
seeing a movie that you're going to be
disappointed in take the 15 20 bucks go
see Corey Feldman um and especially if
you grew up in the 70s or 80s yeah it's
a fun walk down memory lane to have him
tell the stories or sing songs from like
Lost Boys and stuff it was pretty sweet
and it was 15 bucks to go see this guy
uh yeah I mean and now he's on a big
tour he's in fact we were going to
mention this he is calling us from the
Midwest yeah so he it kind of forewarned
does hey listen I'm going through the
Midwest the coverage is pretty shoddy
but I'll do my best to make the call and
hopefully the call sticks but yeah he's
all over the board I mean he's really
just traveling and making this whole
music thing a big part of his life right
now yeah we are five minutes away from
failed manatee a nice Porter would put
it okay um but you think about look
here's the thing it is so easy to watch
those videos on the Today Show it's so
easy to watch those Clips and and think
it's funny sure I say I mean you know I
think especially with the internet these
days
being so cruel and vindictive and
everybody feels safe in a cubicle or in
their home typing mean [ __ ] right I
think the difference when you go to
these shows is that you're actually
listening to the music you're not seeing
the spectacle and you're watching
somebody who is thoroughly giving it one
hundred percent and not phoning it in
right I think that's the difference from
and it's I I'm not saying everybody is
doing that I'm not saying it but when
the Today Show servers crash because
they can't handle at rapid I want to see
it yeah I think there is this curiosity
factor of seeing this kid that was so
iconic with all these movies in the 80s
and inside wait he's doing what he's
right singing and he's he's got these
hot girls dressed as angel what's going
on you know so I think there was a
curiosity factor you said something to
like he's in great shape right you said
he's been really good i gotta tell you
like as a dude who look we're both of a
certain age right we eat on the road
were like we got to get in shape I'm in
a dude he came out to the Lost Boys song
leather jacket yeah no shirt right and i
went to if i was in the shape sure it
looked like he looked like he just got
done doing p90x right and somebody
squirting him down in the back
supporting his habit out if he's awesome
listen aside from his music I mean you
know I I'm gonna go check it out and I'm
sure you're gonna go back to see another
show I'm glad I love his movies I mean
look at all of the movies that he's done
and I mean I don't know if I could
pinpoint just one or two that were my
favorite because there were so many you
know Lost Boys Goonies gremlins license
to draw I mean how many are there I mean
there's just so many great movies that
in terms of our age in our age bracket
yeah that go down in history is easily
some of the best coming-of-age film they
don't stand by me I mean state you look
what stand by me did that influence if
there's no stand by me i don't believe
that there's a wonder years true um and
everybody remembers the pie-eating
contest but it's such a great
coming-of-age film and and all for those
characters you fell for every single one
of them it was so flushed out and well
developed and then I think everybody
coming out at movie I think I know River
Phoenix
going to be this huge star and then you
know look what happens but here we go oh
I'm so excited Stephen we might actually
welcome they want to do it on my room
that's fine but that's one hello hello
how are you buddy hey guys are you doing
dude thank you so much for taking time
to talk with us about about the music
your career everything just we really
appreciate a man honestly thank you so
much no worries it's a little crazy
right now timing is a little weird
because we just pulled into town man
that service for the last few hours to
catch a not into our new hotel so we
actually have to unload the entire RV
right now but I'm going to try and do
this so i probably don't have that long
we'll do the best we can of course
absolutely i gotta you know let's just
and i know i wrote that facebook post
and then you responded to it i just got
to say on behalf of and since i put that
post out there's so many comedians that
truly truly are fans of yours I know
iliza shlesinger just took a picture she
posted it she was at a bar I mean there
were so many comments that we that wrote
me that were so curious about the show
comedians as you know you did an evening
at the improv years ago we can be a
little pessimistic maybe on the negative
side there was a group of us that went
in thinking okay we're going to have
some laughs dude we all came out of it
converted fans and oh thank you i
appreciate i gotta tell you we
absolutely love the show and you could
absolutely care and that's the thing I
really being to perform myself and Gary
and I were talking about other
performers even Porter we talked to him
earlier today Chris Porter another comic
we were talking about so many times you
feel let down by these iconic bands
you'll spend so much money to go see
what is your drive what is it you're
it's almost like I don't know to me it
was almost like you're letting everybody
know hey this is it man I'm into it I
love this and yeah you were going for it
it was absolutely great well you know
it's just a lifetime of being an
entertainer regular to do what I do so
for me it's just you know I'm just doing
another show every night you know I
don't really look at it in any other way
up and you know obviously we're quite
happy that all the shows are
it out and we're quite happy that
there's a good buzz around the thing and
you know obviously the success of the
last album has been tremendous you know
obviously very you know rewarding and
inspirational as an artist because you
know that's what you want and also
coming from a guy who you know it was
almost like it was almost like you know
like my music career was like my dirty
little secrets or like 20 years you know
what I mean like you know we put my
music and films we put out my albums we
did tours but it was like only the cult
the hardcore Colt fans were were about
it until like the biggest thing we did
was the the truth movement performance
at the santa cruz boardwalk where we had
15,000 people and that was the first
time i was like okay this is what it
feels like you know to do a real show
and that was kind of the first one and
then from there it's just gone up and up
and up but it's been you know if you go
back and forth you do one thing and you
make some headway and then you could
kick back and you know of course with
all the the negative press and the
controversy and all that stuff you know
then it sends it back the other way so
this is the problem imagine if every
time you went on stage you know you had
a group of people that were destined to
try to make it look like you're your act
wasn't serious or that you weren't you
know a professional comedian right you'd
be like what the hell like what are you
crazy what I do when talking about it's
my life right you don't I mean but it's
that's almost a feeling is like these
people trying to constantly say oh yeah
but what you do is invalid your music
isn't real your music isn't legit your
music is whatever or your performance
isn't and you just go like are you
talking about because when you look at
the farm painting and this has been the
same since I was a kid I mean I go out
there and people scream you know and
therefore my time and they rock and
everything along the dance whatever you
saw it you know so that's what I
experienced at every show so that's
where you know there's a big disconnect
because on one side i'm looking at every
show I've ever done it's always been the
same people have a great time and my
fans know that it's going to be a
terrific concert but for people who buy
into the media PS and they get caught up
and if they go all it's going to be late
show
or what does get it below it's probably
going to be you know unprofessional and
it's a train record you know it's like
guys come on I've been doing this for 35
years you really think I don't have it
together right now right you know what
how to put a show on you know well what
is it you think that creates the
curiosity factor because the initial
Today Show appearance you guys you crash
The Today Show surfers I mean that's how
that's how much traffic was going and
making this video go viral what what is
it that you think spurred that our first
opportunity to ever perform in front of
a massive audience yeah I mean you got
to realize I've always been kept down
like always like anytime we volunteer
like you know 911 happened i was in 911
there were all those big concerts for
911 I should have been a part of that
because i was there i was part of it I
was with Michael Jackson it was a horse
historic thing I offered my services and
it was like not sorry no room for you on
this telethon no I sorry we can't get
you that spot so all my life every time
I've ever tried to be a part of like the
things that mattered good stuff to do
good charity concerts to do to benefit
performances things like that I've
always been xed out of they've never
given me a primetime spot on a talk show
to perform they've never given me you
know the opportunity to do giant concert
halls and some stadiums and things like
that even though we know we can show
them it doesn't matter if they won't
give us the opportunity because they
don't want to give me the credibility to
make it look like our actors for real
for whatever reason it's this tug-of-war
with the media and this one time it was
like I almost think it was set up in a
way like okay fine let's get rid of him
forever by putting him out there and
putting all this negativity and this
negative press around it can make people
have one good laugh and then he'll get
so humiliated that he'll never come back
you'll be done forever and I really
think that was the intention behind it
and then instead it backfired because
everybody got the opportunity to see
what we do right I me when what are you
talking about it was awesome you know I
want to see one so did you feel open to
a whole can of worms that they just paid
weren't expecting but I knew I knew give
me that shot give me five minutes of
Americans you know attention
we will prove them wrong and did you
feel there was redemption in the terms
of the viewership and the fact that you
got to come back I'll do take a stand a
second looey well not just that but the
redemption also came in the form of
selling out of every copy of my CD you
know it came in you know the form of you
know hitting number 32 on the Billboard
charts for the song go for it I mean you
know came in many forms of validation
but mostly the biggest validation was
the thousands upon thousands of emails
and Facebook messages and Twitter
messages I mean we're talking tens of
thousands of people saying thank you for
continuing to do what you do thank you
for you know not letting them keep you
down because you're my inspiration keep
going for it you're my inspiration to
keep moving forward and that's powerful
you know you start seeing you know kids
who I talked to who are in high school
junior high and they're cutting
themselves or you know they're depressed
because they let people bully them on
you know they don't know how to stop it
and they don't want to go to school
anymore they don't want to they don't
want to wake up every day and you know
they're in severe depressions over it
and they see me who's gone through all
the stuff that I've gone through in my
life great moral station you know Oh
terrible things and all the negative
credits and all this you know crap from
everybody and yet I don't weigh down I
just keep moving forward I go oh well
that's the thing next you know yeah I
know in my heart that my true fans and
there's millions of them all over the
world are going to be there to watch
whatever happens less it's almost like
not worried about you you became a voice
for the underdog is that fair to say in
terms of everything that's gone on since
the videos you know there's no mistake
that the last song on my new album is
working class hero right and if that
says it all here's the thing I words to
that song really they know really you
know identified me in my persona because
it's like you know I've worked my whole
life to be the average guy yeah well I
got to tell you you're not the average
guy working with those angels god bless
you Cory ha i also have to tell you this
you know the thing
is I think so many folks like myself i
was born in 74 I grew up with you you're
a big part of I of my life in terms of
these iconic films and i know you i
identify you so much with these films
but then when you go down the rabbit
hole and you see your career play out on
youtube you that's what i learned you've
been singing the whole time it's my
fault I've known you for Goonies and
stuff so when I see you and Budd
Friedman is introducing you and you're
performing at the improv it's like this
to its been singing the whole time and
you closed your show when you said I I'm
closing the show with a song I wrote
when I was 15 I go look this is going to
be garbage because nothing anything
anybody right to 15 me do it it was the
best song of the night and I'm like that
Michael dude it was [ __ ] awesome I'm
not lying and she said it went on for
like eight or nine minutes you got the
whole thing and you're on the tables
we're all singing at the top of our
lungs I felt like I was at oasis thing
and don't look back in anger I'm like
this is [ __ ] great it's an epic
closer and that's when I really
appreciated the fact that music has been
in your whole life and it was it was
like an education for me now as a fan
that I really appreciated I know Gary
Canada has a question for ya and i was
wondering cory like obviously there were
those times when you wanted those
primetime spot you wanted to jump in and
help out do the telephones for 911 and
everybody kind of shunned you do you
care about doing that stuff now or
because you kind of dumb things away
you're like f you i don't know the
resembles i'm here to help you know i'm
always going to be on the winning team
you know whatever whatever I can do to
push people forward to motivate people
to inspire people to continue doing good
deeds for each other to helping each
other I mean that's what the song it's
are simple is doing we're talking about
that song that's what it's about it's so
simple on the point of the song is that
it's so easy to just give a riddle you
know people are so selfish and they're
so stuck up on their own thing and the
word about money and they're worried
about finance or worried about the
girlfriend I'm worried about whatever
almost like you know in all of our
selfishness and all of our gluttony we
overlook the things that matter most and
we all
so overlooked the simplest solutions and
the simplest solutions really come from
giving because sure tell you how it
works it's it's positive energy creates
positive energy negative energy creates
negative energy now I understand I've
been a comedian too I did stand-up at
when I was certain loans doing stand-up
you know puts a rising star in new york
at the comedy store 31 / I did it all
but I decided early on that I didn't
have the heart for stand-up guys you
know have to have actually tougher skin
and singers do because there's a singer
day there were later they don't but they
don't sit there and you know who use
remote desire so it's all crap see the
whole time yeah it is your performance
it happens but not as you know readily
as as when you're doing stand up when
you're doing stand-up you're really
really going into the war zone you know
and and you know when i'm on a good day
I don't mind bansuri but if I'm feeling
sensitive you know and that's the thing
you know as you know you have to get up
and you have to be funny whether you're
in a good mood or not and i'm not good
at that right i'm good at being funny
when I feel like it but if I don't feel
like it forget it so I knew right away
like I can sing and dance no matter what
mood I'm in because it's letting out you
know this kind of burning fire inside me
but when it comes to comedy it's a whole
different world well I'll oh sorry I
want to Alan I ask you this to you know
I know that there I know you've had this
a friendship with Michael Jackson and
there's a nice tribute in there that you
do but the one thing I think that maybe
there was some correlation between you
two is that when I heard like um the the
song you did on on The Today Show take a
stand where when you performed it live
and it was there was like two or three
other songs like that and it goes back
to what you were saying a second ago
where you almost like are relaying the
message of an outsider but also being
very inclusive of everybody and a loving
message and that's what I was got from
Michael Jackson's music and videos and
that's definitely what I got from it
seemed like your songs and the message
of your songs am I fair to say no that's
beautiful
thank you I really appreciate that that
means that you were tuned in and
actually wisdom you know and that's what
we hope for well you know beyond the
quarry I drove an hour i was definitely
listening to you know you know i'm
seriously you know people drink and make
it there with their buddies and have a
good time and you know whatever and a
lot of times miss it you miss a message
you know because you're not really
listening so you know i always
appreciate it when i find out that
people actually got something from the
show especially something on an elevated
level because that's what it's all about
but that night in particular that you
are at the coach house right I was at
the San Juan Capistrano yeah the coach
out there was the very first I'll right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so at that show
in particular I noticed and it happened
during the second song but it was like
it was kind of cool because like okay
something in your eyes was the first
song and that was fun and everybody was
on her feet but there was this like look
we're like twenty-five percent of the
audience had this kind of like raised
eyebrows smirk on their face like oh
yeah what is going to be about yeah yeah
I'm press me you know that was probably
more so than any other show so far yeah
but we really felt that when we walked
out there because it was a first show
and it was a lot of new people and looky
loos and not you know the regular fan
and so it was like oh you know what are
we gonna be dealing with there and then
when we broke into ascension millennium
the second song it was like halfway
through that song I literally saw that
smirk change on everybody yeah same time
it was like they went from like this
kind of skeptical so I kind of you know
cynical look on their face to like a
really inspired just kind of like
beautiful smile I mean I don't know how
to explain it like there was an
elevation that occurred amongst the
entire room and I felt like we really
did it send together it really felt that
way yeah do you feel like there's almost
like this you know with with that that
portion of the crowd that is going to be
there for the curiosity factor do you
feel that there is this almost like chip
on your shoulder or like a like [ __ ] you
I'm going to prove you wrong dude watch
watch watch what happens I'm a
profession have been not but not in a
nephew sort of way its mooring like a
hey you know what look it I'm going to
bring you
something you didn't expect right now
let's get there together let's go have
this fun together whoops let's light up
tonight and let's let's just being me
awe of the beauty of it all you know
because that's what it's about it's
positive music rusev positive music
positive messages and you know hey it
doesn't hurt to start a bunch of
gorgeous girls all right so you know
there's nothing negative about any of it
you know what I mean so if you walk away
from something negative or with
something negative from its and that's
in your own head and how did you find
the angel how did you find these angels
like the girl that plays the violin and
the keyboard I she put my lane she was
extremely talented yes extremely
talented yes we're very lucky to have
her she's the musical director insights
of the show okay and you know let me
tell you it was no easy feat finding
these girls it's been literally I mean
I'm saying two years of intensive
rehearsal of auditions firings bringing
new girls I mean like literally we've
been refining and refining and refining
this band for two years straight trying
to make the perfect mix of people of
musicianship of talent because at the
end of the day there's you know we're
asking a lot you know who's got to be
young girls got to be beautiful a girl's
got to have a good enough body to wear
that outfit a girl's got to be highly
skilled to be able to play like 30 or
more songs from all types of different
genres and you know they've got to learn
all this material in like well some of
them like drummer who came on literally
11 days before that first show yeah I
had to learn 22 songs in 11 days you
know so we're talking like extreme
professionalism and intensive work
schedule I mean we've been going
non-stop so like you'll notice the band
from the Today Show is a totally
different band then the band that we're
on tour with aside from Brittany the
guitar player she's the only one that's
the same right every and Courtney of
course but I mean like all the other
girls are new and it took us you know a
long time to find those girls and
literally you know we would have these
governors it was a crazy thing with
drummers I don't know what it is but
it's a rock and roll like every rock and
roll band will say the drummer is the
crazy one
we literally went through so many
frickin drummers and every time I'd be
like a goal come in gb gorgeous
beautiful she play it perfectly with
like yeah you're the one inch like yeah
you know what I just realized I can't go
on the road I've got this thing what are
you crazy I think ye go learn about
material backwards and forwards three
songs and come to an audition right
perfectly have everybody love you and
then you talk numbers everything's cool
there but then you're like man you know
I just never mind a kid ruin mine and we
would get stuff like that and it would
drive us crazy so you know and then you
go through 50 girls they can't play or
they don't have the right will so they
don't you know and then you find one
more and then something happens with
that one you get all excited and then
something goes wrong I mean so we add
that on and up and then the other band
members start getting discouraged
because they see one falling out there
like well this isn't for real and we're
never going to make any money at this
event may leave you know it's just to
keep them around to keep everybody sike
to keep everybody excited and moving
forward it's a lot of work and
especially with girls I've never worked
harder in my life to keep a band
together then I have since I've started
producing a female band I mean that
really wow human guys are a cinch I mean
you know it's no problem like hey we got
a gig alright we plan our rehearsal days
we all show up because a gig it's done
but like with these girls it's been
something else but finally finally we
have a solid group of girls that I'm
very proud of I'm very pleased with and
I'm I'm very very excited to move
forward and tour the world with these
girls so I think we've got I think we've
got our solid group now yeah I was going
to say how's the tour going where are
you guys right now where you guys
heading i know we we just pulled in to
green bay wisconsin okay and we're doing
a show here tomorrow night so we've got
the night off looking nice to get out of
the RV and stretch our legs to 24 hours
yeah um but we've been in hell I mean
this has been we call it the angelic rd
which has been anything but and yellow
is like literally blown sport tires on
the road dad like road was greater blow
out like five times so all of our foods
been ruined you can transferring and in
and out of things
I ended up smashing off the back end
going out of a gas station the other day
so our entire back end of the thing
ripped off and we had to duct tape it
back together I mean the heaters been
out we were free we woke up the other
morning cuz we had no furnace I mean you
know electrical problems you name it
literally every problem you can imagine
as done on this freakin road trip but
somehow we persevere we move forward it
makes you strong that were we're here
and we're ready to rock but when you're
when you're driving Corey when you're
driving through the Midwest you got to
stop and get gas somewhere and you go
into like a shell stations anyway like
Rico yeah I was like it's corey feldman
filling up that Winnebago like what's
going on here like is that right what
happens well security security mostly
does it so enough but yeah they'll see
be jumping out you know and going to get
coffee or whatever and you know I drive
half the time on this trip I mean when
we go to the summer tour we're going to
do you know we're talking 40 to 60 gauge
if we do this tour which is you know
looking more and more likely because
we're selling out all the shows and
we're getting offers left and right so
what I'm thinking is we're probably
going to do like a 40 to 60 day tour in
the summer and for that one we're
getting a bus with a bus driver and I'll
be sleeping in the back thank you very
much yeah it's that crazy to think that
the the that you're driving the bus
you're taking it around like you're in
charge of making sure everybody gets
from point A to play you can't let the
drummer drivers yes we have such a
source oh no that's it I mean there's me
and security and we you know we kind of
switch back and forth because you know
we don't want to make the fan do it it
can't drive around right Cory how old
are you by the way 20 to 25 I gotta tell
you say majors Chelsea Handler exactly
Cory I got to tell you came out during
the you sang a song from The Lost Boys
and you came out you got the leather
jacket no shirt I'm like oh [ __ ] this
guy read it and I'm like yeah I [ __ ]
do that if I of that body to god bless
you Cory I mean photo/jack so much well
let me take that Matt it's from a hard
life of vegetarian strict vegetarian
diet you know I don't ever waiver I'm
not
vegetarians almost 30 years and I don't
drink alcohol and I don't do hard drugs
and I don't smoke cigarettes so it's
healthy living you know I'll be wigan
you're gonna have a good body that's
just the way it works that's not us
Steve that is your night go out anywhere
one piece yeah we every week we hit the
road we dedicate yourself yeah for me it
was never about like health really or
even looked it was more about just my
love for animals so I just stopped
eating animals when I was like 12 years
old and didn't realize that I would have
all these benefits derived from it but I
you know I got lucky I guess but is it
lit escape and I worked the road a lot
too and what you know we go to the same
places throughout the Midwest and I'm
sure you guys are hitting is it harder
to eat healthy and all that good stuff
when you're on the road you're so
programmed that's why that's why one of
the things you know the frigerator is
such a big deal for us on the road
because we've got literally all of our
vegetarian food all of our vegan food on
buzz and my wife Courtney she's a strict
vegan so she's got to make fresh vegan
stuff every day she's gonna make it
shapes and group smoothies and you know
all kinds of such as we have to have her
you know a powered veggie max or
whatever sure everything you know we've
got our pressure cookers and they're
scheming so we've got a full throttle
kitchen going in and we pull over every
night we make fresh vegetarian and vegan
food for the plum we feel that way about
arby's I said well we're driving at not
at all Corey I gotta ask you you've had
this storied career I mean you literally
your resume is stack you've done
everything you've been working since you
were you know baby is this the most
gratifying part of your professional
career in terms of you know all those
films yet a by the way yet a string of
films that anybody would be happy to be
associated with one of them right but
you got to do a ton of them is this
though the most gratifying personally
for you being out there with your tunes
that have been with you for so long well
yes I mean this is you know this is
definitely the dream you know this is
what I've been working so hard for
because as I said you know for a long
time it was just getting people to take
it seriously or did you know the
legitimacy of it all you know like come
on guys already Jesus you know I always
say it took me 30 years to summon over
notes excessive music which is literally
what happened right yeah whether like 30
years of like putting out albums and
touring nobody outside of the direct
sand group noticing you know it was like
the rest of the world was just on you
know mute or something and then all of a
sudden with the today show it was like
boom everybody knows mm-hmm and
everybody's into it and it's like cool
you know so now were your stove we're
just stoked I mean there's really no
other way to put it we're so grateful
I'm so happy to be able to do this to
share this music with so many people and
there's so many people wanting to see it
every show is sold out we just found out
you know the next show is sold out and
the next show is sold out it's like
we're selling out every night so I
couldn't be happier with that well there
is another excited which is I still make
films and I still am very proud of my
film work so you know while we're doing
it simultaneously I'm producing a movie
right now for life town about my life
which generally announced in the press
yet but it's happening so literally we
doing both things at the same time so
that's shooting you know I right well
I'm producing it you know over the phone
and through you know text messages and
emails and whatever but I'm basically
trying to be on the set virtually while
I'm out here and then there's another
film that I have coming out which I
started in with a a trend vampire which
is going to be a crazy horror film
that's coming out later this year so
I've got my full production stuff going
on both sides yo and I'm you know and as
long as we're making it I'm proud of it
you know long since you know the days
where I've just been a hired actor are
gone you know understand it's been quite
a few years since you know we just kind
of go on auditions and do all that stuff
I don't do that anymore because that
that stuff was driving me crazy you know
well as long as we're making the film
you know we're producing it from Corey's
angels productions or whatever then I'm
happy well I I do want to ask you this
because look when your best friend's was
the iconic Michael Jackson I know you
guys were tight what do you think he
would say about this moment
right now for you in terms of the
touring you're going out there you're
making music you're selling out what was
pretty great cloud yeah basically some
of a shot that I've seen from the
tributes you know I mean there's some
beautiful shots and beautiful
photography people have been taking some
shots where it's like kind of feeling
similar okay we're like I'm there was
literally there's literally footage that
people put up from the performance or
like waiting that Michael is at us you
know and that's kind of cool because
that means that I'm doing it right you
know and your fans are really really um
they're really gravitating towards that
they really appreciating it so I know
that he would be proud because of their
if they're buying it and they're feeling
it then I know that you'd be proud like
you know we watched dream a little dream
in the movie theater and never around
once me and corey haim went over the
netherlands and showed him dream a
little dream this was like late 90s and
you know you've never seen the movie so
he didn't know anything about it oh I
know that I Dan tilted and he just
started busting up you know cousin kono
clunky come on up that's not good go
quick oh you know you like really into
it so I thought it was funny you know he
always thought it was funny people you
know tributed him in any way but
especially when it was a good friend of
his you know just problem chuckle and
get off on it is so I don't blame them
because I do the same thing I see kids
dressing up like me doing my moves or
whatever and I get the same kind of
reaction i just got it giggle it's cute
it's funny what was what was your
favorite movie to work on well you have
so many great movies that we all love
what was your favorite oh god well to
work on or the kid with the greens of
course because there's a great kid
adventure yeah but you know again I'm
really I'm very favorable to the work I
do today preferably versus a you know
the work i did as a kid because of the
fact that as a kid I was you know I was
a highly gun I was just you know working
soldiers versus now when you know I
actually know what I'm doing and I'm
putting real thought into it I'm putting
real work into it and crafting you know
really trying to make quality work so
you know it's kind of like you know as a
kid I just got really lucky and I was
just kind of bumbling incidents
awesome opportunities but not really
having any appreciation for it well as
now I appreciate everything I get it it
has a little different too because when
you're a kid actor or even when you're
an adult actor everything's taken care
of for you right because obviously
people want to treat you right you're
working on a big budget film there's
craft services everybody's just handling
you because you know you're the star of
a movie and then you go out and do this
road show and like you said you're
working with a busted refrigerator
you're driving the Winnebago like is it
like how different is that for you well
I mean luckily I'm not a jaded the
maniac won't let everybody was good but
you know like this is not my style will
happen I'm a very hands-on guy and you
know like I said just normal guy really
I mean obviously a bit eccentric you
have my nuances but we all do any honest
I would say but you know overall I'm not
own mind getting my hands dirty and you
know it's for the for the good of the
common man shall we say or the column
angel at this point well Corey I gotta
tell you um look I've been a fan I
actually read your your choreography bio
book you're very brave to come out and
reveal and be so open and honest with
the things that you did in that book and
then to see literally like within a year
i'm watching you live and did you you
just seem like a great guy you seem like
it come from a place of positivity and
you're not out there to blame anybody
else you like picking the world up by
its own slacks and getting the work done
on your own and I can't thank you enough
for taking the time man i really
appreciate I bless you thank you and I
wasn't really appreciate you you know
let me say as far as comedians go here
all right i'll take that man you gotta
realize i grew up you know i grew up
like in comedies like that was my life
like literally before music i transfer
give me I mean when I guess it's
probably 5050 because my dad was also in
strawberry alarm clock so I was always
around music but at 15 years old you
know other kids were like trying to get
into Lake clubs or strip bars I was
going to the comedy store well I was
hanging out with Sam Kinison and I spent
mine
you know at the crest hill house and
with all of the guys with Jimmy Schubert
with Todd with others you know Carl
above all those great comedian meeting
and that's where I was raised that was
my education so I did that from like 15
to 18 and then I started like going and
hanging out backstage at all the rock
shows you know what i mean so I
literally got my education from masters
on both sides that's why I feel like you
know generally generally comedians are
really dicks there you know I'd really
unhappy people they're very depressed
people and they usually take that out in
their audience right you know but
there's every once in a while you meet
enlighten comedians that are still funny
still edgy but just don't have to go
around with a chip on their shoulder
Ryan and it's refreshing to see so thank
you guys for being with you all well
dude we wish you ask continued success
on the tour and we will be seeing ya
when I think April 23rd there's a group
of us coming with even more comedians
and dude we're clear it so hard for you
man beautiful why can't we can see you
guys again and we'll get you upstairs
defense we can all take a good picture
hell yeah awesome another story good
luck on the tour stay warm in green bay
all the best to the girls and we'll see
you soon pal thanks for taking the time
for e we appreciate it have a great day
and enjoy that nice warm weather it is
we will thank you buddy how do tomorrow
night alright guys thanks okay bye-bye
wow what a good dude yeah yeah yeah but
that's like when you talk to him you can
hear how like positive and upbeat he is
and you'd think with dude if you read
his book it's just like this guy is
every reason in the world to be angry
important piss ya you know i'd want to
get too graphic into the book but it's
right it's some pretty rough stuff and
you hear how positive he is and that's
also what you see reflected when you see
him live sure um it was just great so i
look forward to seeing him again
hopefully you can join oh I'm coming
yeah yeah you know Steve it's a saturday
night how do you know I'm free I got a I
got we got a rip off that idea from a
keen about doing that talk show face oh
the guest of honor um what did you do so
I'm excited about it yeah
uh which I loved I would just love to be
like in green bay at like you know a
supermarket and be like is that Corey
Feldman pulling up in that RV like with
the but then you see like a girl she
like yeah of course Corey Feldman coming
up I'm telling it that's just [ __ ]
ripped like that fighter man like rim I
back you like it what yeah I guess I
gotta get a vegetarian yeah yeah I got
to stop eat lunch eighth graders whole
math well we cannot sign course all done
enough yeah I would do if there's so
many folks that maybe we'll listen or
you're thinking the worst or you're
gonna think you're going to go to that
show thinking I was going to be a joke
look you're hoax on you the guy is great
he's a [ __ ] great force of energy
very positive and I look forward to
seeing him again yeah Thank You Corey
Feldman for calling in what a great show
i loved it awesome so at cannon comedy
Gary Kennan at steve byrne live my new
show time special tell the damn joke
comes out friday april 7-9 p.m. on
showtime i will be in boston this
weekend cleveland next weekend and we'll
give you some more dates later that's it
thank you for listening everybody
[Music]
ok